speaking of autocad we obviously move up  to revit now revit is one of the be all  end-all softwares on this list it is a  bim software it allows you to model some  of the most complex projects in the  world and some of those projects have  actually been modeled on revit revit has  an extremely steep learning curve but  once you've figured out revit it is a  phenomenal program that you can do  anything that you can imagine it isn't  cheap just like every other  architectural software it is definitely  not cheap revvit is going to cost you  3580 per year if you want to see the  full video and all things architecture  related make sure you hit that subscribe  button